question is do you think that women's
sexual liberation was good for women
when you say sexual liberation can you
expand on that being a hoe
so being partially partially being
being of hope but particularly the
development of birth control in the
1960s that's what changed the game right
because before when girls slept around
there was always the consequence of
possibly getting pregnant but once you
added birth control into it it takes
away the consequence because you can get
an iud and you have a 99 point whatever
percent chance of not getting pregnant
and
what was the question again do is is sex
is women's sexual
liberation
good for women
i'm gonna say no okay just because of
what you've i don't believe i don't like
the idea of birth control i don't like
the fact that it was created just for
women
and so yeah i'm auntie that so
okay what about you i think
um
oh god
it def
it didn't
i yeah i'd say it didn't just because of
the fact that um
i feel like
women
um
it's so i'm trying to like think of like
a best way to say it basically no i
don't agree that it has helped women um
to be liberating
um
but then
again
when it comes to birth control
i feel like i don't necessarily feel
like birth control
helped women be more liberating
necessarily
um
i didn't i don't think they do it for
men they do it for themselves but not
not to have sex
um
whenever whenever or wherever they
wanted
women women so women aren't on birth
control to have sex whenever they want
some women choose not to have children
um regardless not everyone wants to have
children
um
so
when they
like the only purpose of birth control
is to have sex without having kids
no but i mean um i mean i know some
people do it for acne too i'll put that
in there
and for men menstrual yeah yes yes
um but that's why i say it's not solely
just to not have babies mm-hmm but
wouldn't you say the majority
is it's for it is majority is majority
is yeah
um i need to preface this by saying that
i can't have children okay so i know
nothing about birth control i've never
had a period in my life um speaking to
the mic i've never sorry you're right
i'll tell you what let me bring it
around here perfect um i've never had a
period in my life i've uh never take
obviously never taken birth control
don't need to um
but
my general views on sexual liberation
are that um
yes it's helped
because i mean realistically if
if we're all under the illusion right
that women were having great orgasms and
you know and really enjoying sex with
their forced marriage husbands like i
just don't think that's a reality i'm
almost certain that i know people from
two generations before me you know my
grandma and whatever that that didn't
even enjoy sex and i bet your bottom
dollar the reason they didn't enjoy sex
is not because sex is not enjoyable for
them if they it's done right
it's because
they never had she was she was with one
man a whole life like i don't know but
how can you know that's what you want
right
um on the other hand i don't think that
um we we don't do as well in
relationships
yes right i'm sorry out of relationships
so for example i mean i struggle to
orgasm more with uh casual partners it
takes me at least a few times to get
into it and get comfortable with them
and whatever i think that's our that's
our
what do you call it it's like our
um
like like a fear you know what i mean
it's like
you need to get to know someone because
especially sex is a very intimate act
and it can make you as a woman i think
so i hope you'd all agree feel it so so
if um if you're saying that women tend
to have better sex in relationships
wouldn't it make more sense that like
back then people used to get married and
have a relationship yeah and then they'd
be in one long-term relationship because
i think number one the sex education
that you have before that relationship
is never
it's never good enough to let to tell
people exactly what they need to be
doing
um number two i think that to be quite
honest with you like in our current you
know climate we have multiple
relationships through our lives which
teach us things i don't think we're
monogamous creatures well they also
traumatize you oh yeah of course they do
but yeah but life is traumatizing in so
many ways you don't think it's like
better to have less relationships than
more
i mean i mean to a certain degree
because because every time you have you
know if you have a relationship you you
have a heartbreak right to a to a
certain degree i'm not done yeah
but at the same time i just don't think
you can learn everything you need to
learn from one relationship your whole
life it's just
not feasible what are the things that
you think they're not learning
well well well frank's
because arguably you mentioned your your
grandparents right so you said that you
sh arguably she wasn't having good sex
but then what was her what's her metric
for good and bad sex well i mean look i
didn't sit there and have like
i'm just curious
what would the metric be um
because how would she know if she's only
had sex with one person
that's exactly my point yeah but i'm
saying like like so
i'll give you a stat right if a woman's
a virgin when she gets married she has
an 80 chance of being a happy marriage
after 10 years
80 chance okay um on the other hand if a
girl's had sex with more than five
partners it drops to 25 percent
so
yeah and and and i think in the modern
day and age most guys will pray for five
partners
[Music]
so i just i mean look this is the only
problem i have with statistics as much
as i like to follow them to a certain
degree obviously we have to right but i
just think you know when it comes to
reportedly happy marriages i mean really
what is a
fulfilling relationship
a fulfilling relationship well one one
that la i think one metric you can use
is how long it lasts one that lasts but
i mean but i mean realistically
realistically if if we're going by the
premise that women
the the statistic you just said which
means that women would be faithful to
their husband their whole lives right do
you really think their husbands are
being faithful to them
so so is their marriage actually happy
and are they really happy would they
really be happy if they knew
the realities of their marriage which is
probably that their husband was playing
around at some point so so two things
one there's a really big misconception
that that a lot of men are sleeping with
everybody but and the reason that is the
reason women think that men cheat all
the time is because we're all sleeping
with the same ones because if you survey
100 of women on what they want in a guy
they list twenty percent of men
sometimes fifteen sometimes five percent
of men when it comes to dating apps
women only swipe right between five to
twenty percent of the time so it's a
very small percentage of men that even
have the option to cheat
so well well yeah okay but the thing is
i feel like you're talking about stuff
that's modern right
because realistically if we're talking
about marriages in the way that they
used to be that would mean going back in
time when women were oppressed by
marriage
which means that realistically the
husbands having the male privilege they
had would have much more likely been
able to go out and play away i had an
uncle in the uh a great uncle sorry in
the navy and he used to
he's had a wife back here in england and
he used to go to ports in africa he
loved black women so i've probably got
some black
african cousins somewhere
no but i'm just saying that obviously if
that that was a staple
back in the day that was how things
worked i don't think it was with every
relationship but i think it was a lot
well but i'm saying it's still even like
women haven't changed like women still
want the same things they're just
pickier and pickier and pickier so it's
a smaller and smaller percentage of men
so what i'm saying is the majority of
men don't have the option to cheat it's
hard for a guy to get laid
like on on dating apps like where you
can be the most honest about what you
want right women only swipe right five
percent of the time where men swipe up
50 of the time i mean men will have sex
with a hole in the wall
but to kind of continue on that point if
you want to make a comparison between
the modern day and and
back in the day
men had a lot less access really we
lived in small communities and only
people could sleep with the people that
lived in your immediate vicinity your
uncle was different because he was a
sailor now men have a lot more access
through dating apps but the thing is i
think what you're forgetting is that the
reality of it was that men um
you know i don't i don't know the exact
time ago that it was but women actually
had to stay in the house so
men were allowed to galavant and do
whatever they were talking in the mic
sorry men were allowed to galavant
around do whatever they wanted you know
like back in the victorian times ride
horses around the place right while the
women just had to sit at home
wait for them to come round well like
but but freedom comes with
responsibility right so men also had to
fight in wars well we got to stay home
right so they were forced like they they
get drafted
so so you know women we have my body my
choice men don't when they get drafted
yeah but i mean look we're not living in
times where people get drafted to war
anymore are we i mean well because we're
not in a major war but if that i mean
look look what happened in um ukraine
yeah in ukraine all the
feminism went out the window when when
war times came they're like you know
what bring me back to the kitchen
but there goes there goes where i said
there's specific roles in society i do
understand that when men and women have
different strengths and
you know one of one of the things we're
not born to do is fight really
but i definitely think that
the reality is that we've hacked the
reason why feminism even got so much
traction the reason why we're here today
is because women have felt like we've
had to fight for too long
i certainly have felt like that in my
life and i've had a relatively easy life
i like as i could imagine
in terms of women you know what i mean
like i'm probably in there i'm probably
in the like
top [ __ ] 10 of
women with good lives and privilege you
know what i mean so i can imagine that
um you know there were women in so
what have you felt like you've had to
fight for in 2022 um
my voice well 2022
what yeah i don't feel like i have to
fight so much now it was okay 2010 i
don't know whatever
um
i think
i think back then it was just
i mean i was i was a model i was very
like fresh young fit i got
very much
predated upon by men um i would even say
that
uh to go as far as to say that it has
unfortunately like left scars on me um
probably the reason why
uh you know like we're talking about the
um
however many many men you have i do
struggle to find
more meaningful relationships
um but
again i you know that's that that was
what i feel like was the oppression you
know i was like oh you're just a pretty
like men literally taught me as that
just faced like they could manipulate me
use me well but that's that's the job to
be pretty
what would you mean if modeling no yeah
yeah but
i'm not saying that modeling was the
reason why
before modeling it was that you know
what i mean
so even before modeling yeah yeah yeah
because to me like being beautiful is an
advantage there's there's like people
are treated pretty privileged people are
treated better
they get shorter sentencing like for
prison time no okay they're like no i'm
serious like that you get you're more
likely to get a job interview like being
attract like in the top 20 percent of
beauty so being being in the top 20 of
beauty where you could actually get a
modeling contract like that's a huge
advantage in the world yeah no
no there was advantages that i had i'm
not saying that but um
i mean look certainly we have to
remember that my mental state when i was
16 17 18 when every girl
first went out to have sex and
like it was not the same like sex was
painful 20 times before it became all
right um